speaking of conspiracy theories that
actually have truth at the bottom of
them the coronal relief bill the
president signed last month
contains a provision that hasn't gotten
a lot of attention it directs the
director of national intelligence
in consultation with the secretary of
defense and the heads of other agencies
to disclose what they know about ufos
within 180 days so what are they going
to tell us
nick pope is an expert on this subject
he's former uk minister of defense he's
an official of the uk
ministry of defense he joins us tonight
nick thanks so much for coming on what
do you think we're likely to learn
will they obey is the first question
will they actually tell us what they
know and if they do what will they tell
us
well this is going to be a very
interesting year for ufos that's for
sure tucker and yes they will definitely
have to
produce this report within 180 days so
we can get this by late june
um it has to be unclassified
but can have a classified annex so the
answer
uh what what the public will get maybe
not a lot but what the senate
intelligence committee the armed
services committee will get hopefully a
whole lot more and hopefully
some answers to these questions that
we've been asking
for months now what is going on in our
airspace what has the u.s navy
been encountering and what is it that
has been in these
classified briefings that we know some
senators have
already had what do you think they're
likely to reveal
well and it's interesting because
senator marco rubio
said uh he would almost rather
this was alien because if it turns out
to be
china or russia then we're in big
trouble because the sorts of speeds and
maneuvers and accelerations
that these objects are capable of uh
really
is concerning and i i hope that we're
going to find out about that it's
interesting just before christmas
there were some leaks sitting in office
of
naval intelligence is an organization
called the
unidentified aerial phenomena task force
they're probably the ones drafting this
report
some leaks suggest they have not ruled
out
the extraterrestrial hypothesis
yeah and there may be physical evidence
of the existence of these
of these craft whatever they are have
you heard that
yes i've heard talk of so-called meta
materials and i think this report
really will have to disclose i mean what
what the intelligence committee want to
know
is uh ev everything in government is
fragmented they want to know who knows
what
they want a single official named and
put in charge of all this
and this is going to include fbi by the
way as well as the military and
the intelligence community we want
answers
yeah and i don't want to wait till june
when they do it tomorrow morning and
finally declassify the rest of the war
and commission report while they're at
it and
this is just nonsense and and i
appreciate your help on this
hopefully we'll find out very soon thank
you great to see you